optimal at this altitude I can run flat
out for a half mile before my hands
start shaking can I ask you a personal
question
now it seemed a cybernetic organism
living tissue over metal endoskeleton
this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens I get asked all the time
if you could only use one supplement
what would it be and my answer is
inevitably athletic greens it is your
all-in-one nutritional insurance I
recommended it in the 4-hour body did
not get paid for that and I travel with
it to avoid getting sick I take it in
the mornings to ensure optimal
performance it just covers all my bases
if I can't get what I need through whole
food meals throughout the rest of the
day and you can get 50 oh my gosh 50%
off yes 50% off if you go to athletic
greens calm forward-slash Tim that's
athletic greens calm forward-slash Tim
check it out it's tasty but more
important it will help you not screw up
when you're doing your nutritional
planning so for me just covers the bases
takes a load off my mind puts a lot in
my body and check it out athletic greens
calm forward-slash tim this episode is
brought to you by 99designs 99designs is
a great partner for creating and growing
your business it's a one-stop shop for
all of your graphic design needs whether
that's a logo website business card or
anything else I use 99 designs to get
book cover prototypes for the 4-hour
body which went on to become a number
one New York Times best seller I also
use them for banner ads illustrations
and other things with 99designs
designers around the world to compete to
create the best design for you you give
feedback and then pick your favorite you
end up happy or you get your money back
it's very simple you can check out a few
of my own designs and those of yours
meaning Tim Ferriss show listeners at
99designs com forward slash Tim and
right now my listeners you guys will get
a free $99 upgrade on your first design
that's 99 designs com a forward slash
Tim check it out
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show I am so excited for
this episode you have no idea but I'll
try to give you an idea
it's full of announcements full of cool
projects that I've been working on for a
very long time announcement number one
the Tim Ferriss experiment which was an
entire season of television 13 episodes
that was exec producer hosted by yours
truly alongside the Emmy award-winning
team behind no reservations mind of a
chef
etc is now available in not only the US
but also pretty much every country in
the world there are a couple of
exceptions but check it out there are
all sorts of shenanigans adventures
injuries cataclysms etc for our work
week calm /tv
so just go to 4-hour workweek dot-com
/tv all spelled out and you can check
that out you can also see a trailer that
shows you highlights of all 13 episodes
next we have the Tao of Seneca what is
the Tao of Seneca well there's a
collection of letters called the moral
letters to Luke Ilyas and I have read
this entire collection of letters and
other letters of Seneca the author
probably more than 100 times it was my
constant companion for the last 10 to 20
years and I have given various forms of
these letters to more friends than I can
count
and several hundred acquaintances I feel
that strongly about it when people ask
me what my favorite book is of all time
I say this collection of letters the
problem has been there is no good audio
Edition that was the objective so I for
many months now in collaboration with a
fan actually a listener and a reader
John Robinson have been collaborating to
put together the Tao of Seneca subtitle
practical letters from stoic master
three volumes and it covers them all
here's the description the Tao of Seneca
is an introduction to stoic philosophy
through the words of Seneca thought
leaders in Silicon Valley tout the
benefits of stoicism and I'm not just
referring to me
they're not referring to me at all
actually many others and NFL management
coaches and players alike have embraced
it because the principles make them
better competitors stoicism is a
no-nonsense philosophical system
designed to produce dramatic real-world
effects think of it as an ideal
operating system for thriving in high
stress environments this is your guide
and you can find this on audible
audible.com for word slash Tim's books
that will take you to my book club where
I acquire audio rights and produce books
that have had a huge impact on my life
this is at the top of the list tab
Seneca number one most impactful
collection of writing on my life period
so please check it out audible.com
forward slash Tim's books and there's a
sample in this episode that is what this
episode consists of letter thirteen
specifically on groundless fears it is a
12 minute letter I think you'll enjoy it
greatly give it a few minutes get warmed
up Seneca sometimes has a bit of a
preamble at the beginning of his letters
and I'll also give you the preface to
the book that I put together which will
give you a lot more context but on this
letter specifically on groundless fears
give it a couple of minutes and also for
the women listening this is 2000 years
old and Seneca makes comments like
manliness gains much strength from dot
dot dot dot dot right you can just
substitute humans and it is as
applicable to women as it is to men
certainly and at the end of the preface
I list off some of my favorite letters
so you can jump around and pick and
choose I encourage you to treat the town
of Seneca as a buffet of letters you can
choose from and revisit often and if you
do decide to get the volume one for
instance
volume 2 volume 3 I do have a very long
version an essay version of on the
shortness of life to start off with that
is a long one that is about an hour hour
and a half you can skip over that if
it's too long that is where I'll leave
things I'm so excited to bring this to
you and so excited for you if you
haven't heard Seneca before you will
hear the preface
you can skip through that if you want
which I read and then letter 13 on
groundless fears
check it out the table Seneca
audible.com forward slash Tim's books
enjoy this is Tim Ferriss speaking the
producer of this audiobook I have an
author perhaps best known for books with
titles that sound like infomercial
products the 4-hour workweek in the
4-hour body which are published in about
45 languages or so and I am a tech
investor and I've been involved early
stage in companies like Facebook Twitter
Boober Alibaba and perhaps 30 others I
only bring up this background because I
credit my successes whatever they might
be in many fields including those tengo
etc - stoicism and to reading the
writing of specifically Seneca and that
is why I have put so much time into
assembling and compiling this book and
with the help of John bringing it to you
that is the narrator John Robinson few
of us consider ourselves philosophers of
course and this is usually for very good
reasons most of us can recall at least
one very irritating pseudo-intellectual
probably in college who dedicated
countless hours to some type of
philosophical tail-chasing and so we
associate philosophy with this type of
behavior for what well maybe this person
was debating what is is
but somehow posturing as a superior
intellect at meal time or over drinks
it's very irritating it's very useless
and not unlike the bar scene in Good
Will Hunting perhaps but it is for
academics and I think it is for theory
these are beliefs that many of us have
about philosophy it's something that you
do over wine for fun but it doesn't
apply to real life fortunately there are
a few no-nonsense philosophical systems
that can produce dramatic real-world
effects and results these were forged
and refined in action sometimes war
stoicism is to me perhaps one of the
best examples of that and that's what
we'll focus on think of it as an ideal
operating system for thriving and high
stress environments and that is
certainly why it's gained a huge
foothold in Silicon Valley as one
example in professional sports
so if you study stoicism you'll be in
very good company
it's a rulebook for making better
decisions it was popular with the
educated elite of the greco-roman Empire
but Thomas Jefferson also had Seneca on
his bedside table
Montaigne had a quote from Epictetus
carved into the ceiling of his house
where he would see it constantly
Bill Clinton reads meditations by Marcus
Aurelius every year in the NFL and this
has become big news with an article in
Sports Illustrated management coaches
and players alike including teams like
the Patriots and Seahawks have embraced
stoicism because it makes them better
competitors other proponents include
John Stuart Mill and Tom Wolfe as I
record this
you might hear that my voice is a little
hoarse I just finished a 10-day
water-only fast and I don't necessarily
recommend doing that but it's part of a
practice that comes directly from the
writing of Seneca specifically letter 18
which you'll hear on festivals and
fasting and here is an excerpt to give
you a flavour set aside a certain number
of days during which you shall be
content with the scan theists and
cheapest affair with coarse and rough
dress saying to yourself
all the while is this the condition I so
feared it is precisely in times of
immunity from care that the soul should
toughen itself beforehand for occasions
of greater stress and it is while
fortune is kind that it should fortify
itself against her violence and it goes
on and on but that particular passage
and there's there's a lot more context
to it led me to the practice of taking a
few days per month to eat the cheapest
of food so for instance rice and beans
every meal rice and beans costs one to
two dollars a day if you break it down
wearing the same clothing so the same
white t-shirt and pair jeans remaining
unshaven asking myself all the while is
this the condition I so feared what does
that mean it means that you are
inoculating yourself against unfounded
fears because when I find myself
defensive fearful of losing whatever
success or money or prestige or status I
might have whatever that is or it could
be any number of other types of fears
usually nebulous you worried that your
quality of life will drop you'll be very
unhappy but if you rehearse that
condition the worst case scenario you
realize that it's not that bad and that
is tremendously empowering it allows you
to make better investment decisions it
allows you to take the steps to start
your own company quit your job start a
relationship and a relationship because
you are rehearsing the worst case
scenarios instead of letting them bounce
around in your skull in a very unformed
nebulous way so that is one of dozens of
examples that I could give you the
principles are timeless and incredibly
practical and I particularly like Seneca
I love marcus aurelius I loved Epictetus
but I particularly love Seneca because
it's easy to read it's pithy and the
practices can be applied directly to
your life now if you were to take some
of these letters and replace the names
Luc Ilyas and other Roman sounding names
with John Mary Edward they would read
like letters from one of your
contemporary friends to another hey John
so sorry to hear that you're dealing
with that frivolous lawsuit let me tell
you how I handled this and how I deal
with backstabbing in the Senate and give
you a few tips hey Mary I'm so sorry to
hear that
your friend's mother passed away here's
how you might console her etc etc they
are extremely memorable and that is
because Seneca was one of the most
famous playwrights of his day and that
leads to another point his principles
his philosophies were used on the front
lines he was one of the wealthiest
people in Rome as in effect an
investment banker suppose you can think
of him as such he was also an advisor to
the Emperor that didn't always work out
all too well for him but that's part of
stoicism the point being that he was
world-class in several fields he had to
deal with uncooperative powerful in many
cases human beings all the time and he
was able to do well and I think that's
what separates the Philosopher's so to
speak who actually can put rubber to the
road and make things happen and
philosophy
just as many other people have said
those people who speculate the armchair
quarterbacks Seneca was not one of these
people he was he was getting his hands
dirty and doing big things and the way I
suggest you approach this this is
certainly the way I have approached it
and many people have is making Seneca
part of your daily practice and the way
that you do that is set aside 10 to 15
minutes a day for me it is often walking
to get my morning cup of coffee and I
will listen to one letter a day and this
is highly therapeutic it is highly
effective as a habit if you want to be
more successful in any area personal or
professional stoke principles are often
practiced in rehabilitation clinics for
instance with alcoholics they don't
succumb to impulses in the most
practical sense I suppose it does share
a lot in common with cognitive
behavioral therapy in a sense you could
think of it as putting the first portion
of the serenity prayer into action which
reads in many translations of course as
God grant me the serenity to accept the
things I cannot change the courage to
change the things I can and the wisdom
to know the difference stoicism is the
training ground for putting this into
action so you have to digest it just
like good nutrition a little bit every
day put in the time one letter 5 to 15
minutes it might have been born on the
porch of xeno but it can be used
everywhere in the concrete jungle and
I'll recommend a few letters to start
with if you want to bounce around I
suggest you listen to all of them they
will apply to you in your life at
different points three of my favorites
are 13 18 and 27 so letter 13 on
groundless fears letter 18 on festivals
and fasting letter 27 on the good which
abides which is also hilarious John
Robinson his favorites do not overlap
they will be very personal but if you
want a few recommendations to start with
start at the beginning of this audio
book vol 1 because it features on the
shortness of life which I read and
listen to at least once a quarter
usually once a month and then letters 13
18 and 27
and I have to before I part give a
heartfelt thanks to John Robinson John
Robinson I found on the Internet I was
searching for an audio book of Senecas
letters and essays and I couldn't find
it and then one day John Robinson's
website pops up it turns out he's a fan
of mine and the 4-hour workweek heard me
talking about Seneca in many different
interviews tried to find an audio book
also couldn't decided to make it himself
and put together I think it was 10 to 30
draft essays I downloaded them when I
was in Costa Rica and needed some
recalibration I needed to address some
unfounded fears of my own and I was
blown away whatever voice I had in my
head for Seneca it was John it was
perfect and I reached out to him we
started to collaborate we put this
entire thing together and he has just
been a superstar so thank you very much
John and thank you to all of you for
listening I am so excited and envious of
you in a way if you've never heard or
been exposed to Seneca before and as he
would say
take care letter thirteen on groundless
fears
I know that you have plenty of spirit
for even before you began to equip
yourself with Maxim's which were
wholesome and potent to overcome
obstacles you were taking pride in your
contests with fortune and this is all
the more true now that you have grappled
with fortune and tested your powers for
our powers can never inspire in us
implicit faith in ourselves except when
many difficulties have confronted us on
this side and on that and have
occasionally even come to close quarters
with us it is only in this way that the
true spirit can be tested the spirit
that will never consent to come under
the jurisdiction of things external to
ourselves this is the touchstone of such
a spirit no prize fighter can go with
high spirits into the strife if he has
never been beaten black and blue the
only contestant who can confidently
enter the lists is the man who has seen
his own blood who has felt his teeth
rattled beneath his opponent's fists who
has been tripped and felt the full force
of his adversary's charge who has been
downed in body but not in spirit one who
as often as he falls rises again with
greater defiance than ever
so then to keep up my figure fortune has
often in the past got the upper hand of
you and yet you have not surrendered but
have leapt up and stood your ground
still more eagerly for manliness gains
much strength by being challenged
nevertheless if you approve allow me to
offer some additional safeguards by
which you may fortify yourself there are
more things looky-loos likely to
frighten us than there are to crush us
we suffer more often in imagination than
in reality I am NOT speaking with you in
the stoic strain but in my milder style
for it is our stoic fashion to speak of
all those things which provoke cries and
groans as unimportant and beneath notice
but you and I must drop such great
sounding words although heaven knows
they are true enough what I advise you
to do is not to be unhappy before the
crisis comes since it may be that the
danger is before which you paled as if
they were threatening you will never
come upon you they certainly have not
yet come accordingly some things torment
us more than they ought some torment us
before they ought and some torment us
when they ought not to torment us at all
we are in the habit of exaggerating or
imagining or anticipating sorrow
the first of these three faults may be
postponed for the present because the
subject is under discussion and the case
is still in court so to speak that which
I should call trifling you will maintain
to be most serious for of course I know
that some men laugh while being flogged
and that others wince at a box on the
ear we shall consider later whether
these evils derive their power from
their own strength or from our own
weakness do me the favor when men
surround you and try to talk you into
believing that you are unhappy to
consider not what you hear but what you
yourself feel and to take counsel with
your feelings and question yourself
independently because you know your own
affairs better than anyone else does ask
is there any reason why these persons
should condole with me why should they
be worried or even fearsome infection
from me as if troubles could be
transmitted is there any evil involved
or is it a matter merely of ill report
rather than an evil
put the question voluntarily to yourself
am i tormented without sufficient reason
am i morose and do I convert what is not
an evil into what is an evil you may
retort with the question how am I to
know whether my sufferings are real or
imaginary
here is the rule for such matters we are
tormented either by things present or by
things to come or by both as to things
present the decision is easy suppose
that your person enjoys freedom and
health and that you do not suffer from
any external injury as to what may
happen to it in the future we shall see
later on today there is nothing wrong
with it
but you say something will happen to it
first of all consider whether your
proofs of future trouble are sure for it
is more often the case that we are
troubled by our apprehensions and that
we are mocked by that mocker rumor which
is want to settle Wars but much more
often settles individuals yes my dear
Luke Elias we agree too quickly with
what people say we do not put to the
test those things which cause our fear
we do not examine into them
we blench and retreat just like soldiers
who are forced to abandon their camp
because of a dust cloud raised by
stampeding cattle or are thrown into a
panic by the spreading of some
unauthenticated rumor and somehow or
other it is the idle report that
disturbs us most for truth has its own
definite boundaries but that which
arises from uncertainty is delivered
over to guesswork in the irresponsible
license of a frightened mind that is why
no fear is so ruinous and so
uncontrollable as panic fear for other
fears are groundless but this fear is
witless
let us then look carefully into the
matter it is likely that some troubles
will befall us but it is not a present
fact how often has the unexpected
happened how often has the expected
never come to pass and even though it is
ordained to be what does it avail to run
out to meet your suffering you will
suffer soon enough when it arrives so
look forward meanwhile to better things
what shall you gain by doing this time
there will be many happenings meanwhile
which will serve to postpone or end or
pass on to another person the trials
which are near or even in your very
presence a fire has opened the way to
flight men have been let down softly by
a catastrophe
sometimes the sword has been checked
even at the victims throat men have
survived their own executioner's even
bad fortune is fickle
perhaps it will come perhaps not in the
meantime it is not so look forward to
better things the mind at times fashions
for itself
false shapes of evil when there are no
signs that point to any evil it twists
into the worst construction some word of
doubtful meaning or it fancies some
personal grudge to be more serious than
it really is considering not how angry
the enemy is but to what lengths he may
go if he is angry but life is not worth
living and there is no limit to our
sorrows if we indulge our fears to the
greatest possible extent in this matter
let prudence help you and contempt peer
--it even when it is in plain sight
if you cannot do this counter one
weakness with another and temper your
fear with hope there is nothing so
certain among these objects of fear that
it is not more certain still that things
we dread sink into nothing and that
things we hope for mock us accordingly
way carefully your hopes as well as your
fears and whenever all the elements are
in doubt decide in your own favor
believe what you prefer and a fear wins
a majority of the votes incline in the
other direction anyhow and cease to
harass your soul reflecting continually
that most mortals even when no troubles
are actually at hand or are certainly to
be expected in the future become excited
and disquieted no one calls a halt on
himself when he begins to be urged ahead
nor does he regulate his alarm according
to the truth no one says the author of
the story is a fool and he who has
believed it is a fool as well as he who
fabricated it we let ourselves drift
with every breeze we are frightened at
uncertainties just as if they were
certain we observe no moderation the
slightest thing turns the scales and
throws us forthwith into a panic
but I am ashamed either to admonish you
sternly or to try to beguile you with
such mild remedies let another say
perhaps the worst will not happen
you yourself must say well what if it
does happen let us see who wins
perhaps it happens for my best interests
it may be that such a death will shed
credit upon my life
Socrates was ennoble by the hemlock
draught wrenched from Cato's hand his
sword The Vindicator of Liberty and you
deprive him of the greatest share of his
glory
I am exhorting you far too long since
you need reminding
rather than exhortation the path on
which I am leading you is not different
from that on which your nature leads you
you were born to such conduct as I
described hence there is all the more
reason why you should increase and
beautify the good that is in you but now
to close my letter I have only to stamp
the usual seal upon it in other words to
commit there to some noble message to be
delivered to you
The Fool with all his other faults has
this also he is always getting ready to
live
reflect my esteemed looky-loos what the
saying means and you will see how we're
voting is the fickleness of men who lay
down everyday new foundations of life
and begin to build up fresh hopes even
at the brink of the grave look within
your own mind for individual instances
you will think of old men who are
preparing themselves at that very hour
for a political career or for travel or
for business and what is baser than
getting ready to live when you are
already old
I should not name the author of this
motto except that it is somewhat unknown
to fame and it is not one of those
popular sayings of Epicurus which I have
allowed myself to praise and to
appropriate
farewell
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email from me
every Friday that provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
99designs 99designs
is a great partner for creating and
growing your business it's a one-stop
shop for all of your graphic design
needs whether that's a logo website
business card or anything else I use 99
designs to get book cover prototypes for
the 4-hour body which went on to become
a number one New York Times best seller
I also use them for banner ads
illustrations and other things with
99designs
designers around the world to compete to
create the best design for you you give
feedback and then pick your favorite you
end up happy or you get your money back
it's very simple you can check out a few
of my own designs and those of yours
meaning Tim Ferriss show listeners at
99designs com forward slash Tim and
right now my listeners you guys will get
a free $99 upgrade on your first design
that's 99 designs com a forward slash
Tim check it out this episode is brought
to you by athletic greens I get asked
all the time if you could only use one
supplement what would it be and my
answer is inevitably athletic greens it
is your all-in-one nutritional insurance
I recommended it in the 4-hour body did
not get paid for that
and I travel with it to avoid getting
sick I take it in the mornings to ensure
optimal performance it just covers all
my bases if I can't get what I need
through whole food meals throughout the
rest of the day and you can get 50 oh my
gosh 50% off yes 50% off if you go to
athletic greens comm forward-slash Tim
that's athletic greens comm
forward-slash Tim check it out it's
tasty but more important it will help
you not screw up when you're doing your
nutritional planning so for me just
covers the bases takes a load off my
mind puts a lot in my body and check it
out athletic greens calm forward-slash
Tim if you want more of the Tim Ferriss
show you can subscribe to the podcast on
iTunes or go to for our blog comm fo you
Rho R PLO T comma where you'll find an
award-winning blog tons of audio and
video interview stories with people like
Warren Buffett and Mike Shinoda from
Lincoln Park the books plus much much
more follow tim on twitter at
twitter.com/dspacestv or Riss or on
facebook at facebook.com slash Tim
Ferriss until next time thanks for
listening